she was as much a monster as clarissa or
amos had ever been she was someone who'd
found a way to save her little chosen
family when everything seemed lost the
two didn't balance but they existed
together pain and relief sorrow and
contentment the evil and the redeeming
could sit together in her heart live
together and neither one take the edge
off the other and jim knew that he
didn't ask because he needed an answer
he asked because he needed her to know
the answer mattered to him that was all
i'm all right she said the way she
always did jim reached out his other
hand and dimmed the lights naomi closed
her eyes they felt comfortable that way
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about the ending of the expanse season 6
episode 6 babylon's ashes is the series
finale at least for now the conflict
with the free navy is over things are
looking optimistic for the belters and
the crew of the rossi have made it
through to the other side of their
years-long journey this was a moving
hour of television that paid off so much
that had been set up and there's a lot
to talk about in this season finale so
i'll just give you this quick spoiler
warning if you haven't watched the
finale of season six of the expanse then
this video won't be for you and with
that out of the way let's get into it
the finale opens with winston duarte
looking up at the orbital platforms in
the laconia sky and it does look as
though cortisar was able to activate the
gate builder tech that was left behind
this is good news for the breakaway
martian fleet he brought through the
laconia gate but there were other side
effects from bringing the active
proto-molecule sample to the planet that
had been playing out in the first five
episodes of the season with the
emergence of what carrick called dogs in
the forest he saw that they were able to
reanimate her deceased brother zan and
in the finale she brings him home her
parents are horrified and when her
father slashes him with a knife you see
that his blood is black and his wound
heals almost instantly they lock him in
a cabinet and call the soldiers cara
uses her hand terminal to distract her
parents and they escape into the forest
together she isn't worried that there
isn't any food she can eat in the
laconia wilderness because she thinks if
she dies the dogs will just fix her you
get a glimpse of what the world looks
like through his new eyes and their
story ends there for now the laconia
segment ends with duarte looking up as
something is being constructed on the
platforms there's still a lot of mystery
around this part of the story and most
of it isn't answered until the final two
books so i won't be explaining what's
happening here because that would
involve future spoilers
in soul system the battle is starting to
take shape the free navy split their
forces into three groups to approach the
ring gate the strength of their warships
are concentrated into two of those which
the unn and mcrn will pursue leaving the
third group for drummer's fleet if they
fail to stop them the free navy will be
able to establish themselves in the ring
space behind the rail guns wherein
abisarala's words they'll be dictating
the fate of our species for a generation
holden explains that they have a plan b
that involves breaking for the ring gate
during the battle they think they have a
way to distract the railguns long enough
to land a strike team on the ring
station and take control of them on the
rossi the crew is finally starting to
come back together as they burn for the
ring after clarissa gets the
heartbreaking news that she probably
only has five years to live she makes a
big dinner for everyone this brings back
memories of lasagna in season 2 and
reinforces the idea that their little
family has changed but will continue on
if they survive the upcoming mission in
the confrontation with the free navy the
abasarala-led unnn battle group 1 thinks
they've identified the pella this
concerns drummer's group because they
worry that they'll be cut out of future
plans if they don't play a direct role
in killing him although walker is still
happy to do some piracy
things take a turn when they realize
that marcos spoofed the drive signature
data and camouflaged the pella as a
freighter and the group that drummer is
engaged with when it sheds its disguise
it's able to dominate the fight against
the belter ships and nearly destroys the
tynan when drummer assesses her
situation the hall tour ship is filled
with holes the drive is damaged to the
point that it will fail if they continue
to use it and they're all out of
torpedoes she tells the rest of her
fleet to disengage and decides to try a
suicide mission to ram the pella before
it can get away when she's warned that
her reactor will overload she responds
that will help but before she can go
through with it walker makes a move to
do the same thing he delivers a farewell
message and she watches him until his
comms cut out his ship is cut to pieces
by the pdcs but it's still on a
collision course another ship tries to
ram it but it still manages to damage
the pella rosenfeld takes massive
injuries in the collision and philip is
there to watch her die the pellet is
damaged but it's still able to make its
way to the ring meaning that the united
fleet failed in their mission that means
the outcome of the war depends on who
controls the rail guns in the ring space
and as the gian batista and the rossi
arrive at the ring you get an idea of
how they plan to do that the hauler is
filled with hundreds of drone crafts
that will be released to flood the ring
space to act as a diversion to keep the
guns occupied there will be a ground
assault team mixed in with the mass of
vessels who will focus on making it to
the ring station naomi will try to
assist those manned pods while the rossi
tries to use their railgun to disable
medina's calms and defenses it's an
ambitious plan that's up against a lot
of unknowns and things start to go wrong
right away the pods are getting
destroyed at a higher rate than was
anticipated and the rossi takes damage
and starts to lose power in their
reactor clarissa gets her moment to step
up in amos's absence and you see him
eject from his pod at something like 15
g's as the ground assault starts to take
shape and thus begins what has to be the
most thrilling assault sequence ever
seen on tv the rossi does manage to put
medina station between them and the
railguns and is able to neutralize its
weapons and communication systems that
clears the path for the assault team but
they'll run into heavy reinforcements on
the surface you see amos struggle
against pure chaos on his descent and
see medina overhead just before he
touches down their objective is to take
over the control bunker but they get
pinned down by the troops stationed
there and reinforcements overhead from
medina when they learn the other teams
can't help and the rossi can't provide
air cover amos decides to go down in a
blaze of glory saying he'd rather get
shot in the front instead of the back
and bobby agrees at the same time holden
makes the decision to make a last-ditch
effort which will likely mean
sacrificing the rossi but as amos is
rallying the remaining members of the
strike team bobby takes matters into her
own hands using her suits thrusters to
get close enough to the target she
realizes she won't be able to take over
the control bunker and shifts her plan
to using rpgs to destroy the guns
instead she's able to take out the
target but then starts to take heavy
fire from all sides she sees an enemy
with an rpg getting ready to end her but
amos emerges to take him out he gets
shot and it looks like they'll die there
but with the guns disabled the rossi is
able to swoop in and clear the remaining
threats this is a victory as far as
opening up the ring space but it doesn't
win them medina and without the railguns
they're now defenseless for when marco
and his fleet arrive they win the day
but it looks like it's only a temporary
victory that they'll pay for with their
lives on the pella marco gets a message
from duarte who denies his request for
additional armaments now that he's
tucked himself away with his
protomolecule sample and has the orbital
platforms up and running for
construction he no longer needs the free
navy he tells him he was a useful
distraction but that he has gods to kill
and informs him that the ring to laconia
is now closed this is actually news to
marco who saw himself as an equal to
duarte and he's infuriated but quickly
has to hide that when philip comes to
see him they talk about rosenfeld's
death and the sacrifice people are
making for what marcos says is the cause
and we see that the spell has been
broken philip sees his father for who he
is he remembers what his mother told him
in the last season and when marco goes
out among his crew to give a stirring
speech where we see him at his best
telling them that they've been bloodied
but the inners have been broken and that
their end will be the belter's beginning
and everyone joins in a chant except for
philip who sits at his station looking
dejected
inside the ring space the crew of the
rossi runs through their options that
are pretty much exactly running away or
standing up to an unwinnable fight amos
reads the room and asks does anyone here
want to cut and run and they all decide
to resign themselves to their fate with
the intention of at least trying to take
marco with them on their way out as
naomi is looking at the battle data she
notices that some of the pods started to
disappear on transit at the end of their
assault and she thinks this means they
might be able to trigger the ring
entities if they push every bit of mass
and energy they can through the ring all
at once they should be able to wake them
up and even though holden is worried
they might stay awake this is really
their only shot at winning this battle
as the pellet approaches we see the crew
in their battle stations in case it
doesn't work they're ready to fight like
hell if necessary they send the gian
batista ahead to transit the ring right
before marco gets there and naomi waits
to overload its reactor to trigger this
effect she thinks about philip as a baby
as she waits thinking that she'll be
killing him if this plan works and as
the pella begins its transit you see
them start to disappear just like the
bar keith did at the end of season 5.
marco only has moments to understand
that there's something wrong but it does
appear that he knows defeat at his end
the plan works and marco dies as the
pella and the rest of his fleet
disappear you see the members of the
rossi family breathe a sigh of relief
knowing that they're going to live
through the day and then naomi screams
for the loss of her child during
negotiations on series you learn that
inners and the belt agree that they need
to control traffic through the ring
gates now that they know what makes
ships disappear they want to create an
organization to oversee things but reach
an impasse because drummer won't agree
on the inners having two votes and the
belt only having one they explain their
concerns about being political suicide
to put a belter in charge and drummer
explains that this is always the way
things turn out this is always the
excuse that it's not convenient to deal
with the belt they'll do that when they
get the chance down the road and that
she's there to make sure that the belt's
interest aren't overlooked holden speaks
up to say that marco wasn't all wrong
the people of the belt looked at the
future and they weren't in it that's
what this trade union would need to fix
as he's talking abbasarala gets an idea
to create an independent agency they
could pick someone who was apolitical
with a history of working honorably with
all sides everyone starts looking at
holden since he's the only one that fits
that description and when he tries to
decline abisarala says james it's time
to make history again and boy does he he
says he might be open to it but he would
need certain assurances in writing and
when he goes in front of the press to
explain this new transport union just as
everything seems to be falling in place
he gets to the end of his prepared
statements and goes off script before he
accepted the position he made sure the
drummer would be his vice president and
says that he'll always be considered an
outsider so for his first act as
president he'll resign drummer will take
his place as a true belter leading an
independent belter run agency avasarala
calls him a duplicitous little [ __ ] and
says shall undo this because he was
negotiating in bad faith he urges her
not to saying it was the only way to
secure the piece and move forward
together and she knows it she sighs
realizes she's been beat at her own game
and says she hopes he's right and they
shake hands we see the rossi leave
series with bobby in the pilot's chair
we can presume that now that mars is
over and her time with abasarala has
passed that she'll stay on as a member
of the crew clarissa makes a replacement
for the pin that amos wore throughout
the series but lost when he turned over
his jacket to security when he went to
visit her in the pit this is something
he got as a kid from a friend who
decided to take his own life rather than
endure the continual abuse they were
subjected to as they grew up when she
pins it on him she reveals she made one
for herself and they share a smile in
their quarters naomi says she never
thought she'd see an earther taking
orders from a belter and jim says he
pissed off a lot of people then she
starts to talk and she pretty much lays
out the whole underlying theme of this
story and i think it's worth repeating
here you followed your conscience in
hopes that others would follow theirs
you didn't do it for a reward or a pat
on the head the universe never tells us
if we did right or wrong it's more
important to try to help people and to
know that you did more important that
someone else's life gets better than for
you to feel good about yourself you
never know the effect you might have on
someone not really maybe one cruel thing
you said haunts them forever maybe one
moment of kindness gives them comfort or
courage maybe you said the one thing
they needed to hear it doesn't matter if
you ever know you just have to try as
she's talking you see that during
marco's speech on the pella philip left
his post and boarded the repair skiff he
left before they started burning for the
ring and survived to start a new life
away from his father you see him doing
that as he enters his name as philip
nagata after her words holden starts to
talk about what they might do for work
now that the war is over and mentions
how the protomolecule sample is still
missing and naomi smiles and tells him
let's just stay here for a minute it
cuts to an exterior shot of the rossi
and you watch it as it moves into the
distance until you can no longer see it
and the series ends there in the closing
credits scene you can make out the
orbital platforms behind the names and
start to see hints of the red that's
there when ships disappear after the
energy threshold was met a hint that
something ominous awaits if the rest of
the series is ever adapted the end of a
beloved tv series is always a
bittersweet occasion and in the case of
the expanse a little more so considering
we know there's more to the story season
six had some external forces that made
things difficult here and i think that
all things considered they delivered an
ending that does the story and the
characters justice if holden has a
superpower it's that he can still see
the good in humans even when faced with
overwhelming evidence to the contrary at
its core the idea of trying to make the
world a better place in your small
corner of the solar system and following
your conscience with no expectation of a
reward in hopes that others might do the
same comes out again and again and even
though the politics are complicated and
a purely happy ending feels like it
would be pretty fragile having drummer
end up as the trade union president is a
satisfying conclusion the show switched
some things up and holden accepting the
job just to resign and i like the added
dimension of them outplaying avasarala
as the way to make that happen marco
relearned the lesson that the inners
will never see belters as equals the
hard way and becoming duarte's useful
idiot and i always thought of philip's
ending as being the product of being
born into an impossible situation he's
given a chance to maybe make up for his
crimes but he has to do it himself if
you think about it he can't really even
try to reunite with his mother
considering the circumstances she has to
mourn his death in a situation where she
chose the family she found and there's a
nice line from just before what i read
at the beginning that sums this up i
will carry this guilt and sadness for
the rest of my life was just as true as
i lost my son years ago her comfort was
that she was still alive that jim was
and amos and alex bobby and clarissa
there's the idea that both of these
things can exist together without
necessarily canceling each other out and
i think that ties into what we heard at
the beginning of all the x-ray features
this season in the doctrine of one ship
there's just one hole with countless
parts working together like the cells of
a single organism there are factions and
tribes in different political interests
inequalities built into the system and
exploitation that creates conditions
where people like marco can emerge and
if you throw in something like the proto
molecule and the opening of the ringgate
network that connects to all these new
systems with resources free for the
taking that's the impetus for conflict
on the civilizational scale i think the
message is a hopeful one rooted in
realistic relatable characters that also
happen to fly around in spaceships the
political tensions make sense and bring
out the best and the worst of humanity
in the end the wars are over and the
belters have a brighter future and
fighting for the people you care about
still matters i'm sad the expanse is
over but glad i got to experience it and
i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know what you thought
about the finale in the final season and
the series as a whole in the comments
there were a lot of famous sci-fi
characters that made the ultimate
sacrifice in that assault on the ring
station there's so much great character
stuff in the finale and will be diving a
lot deeper into that in the live stream
which i'll put a link to in the pinned
comment if you feel unsatisfied with
where the proto-molecule storyline was
left i highly recommend reading the
books to see what happens with that the
ending is also very satisfying i have a
couple of other videos planned to put
out over the next week so make sure you
check back for those please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon